it's time to talk about those
controversial special editions and when
I say controversial I mean geeks
complaining about stuff that's clearly
not but more gates is what we do in the
mid 90s George Lucas re-released the
Star Wars films on the big screen which
was a big deal a lot of us never saw it
on the big screen so this was something
really wonderful to see and on top of
that he updated a lot of the effects
added new scenes and gave it a total
digital clean up people freed they
couldn't stand the idea that he went and
changed up something that was so perfect
how dare you touch even one frame of
this everything about it is absolutely
magnificent how dare you my take on it I
actually think it's kind of cool it's
kind of nice to see a little bit of an
update it was also a clever way to get
new and younger audiences into the seats
yeah I don't like it either but you know
there's a lot of younger people out
there they say oh the effects they look
fake now so I don't like it
and on top of that Lucas said this was
the version he always wanted to see this
is a world where there was no limitation
he could show much more of Cloud City he
could show much more of Moss Eisley he
could have a bigger dance number in
Jabba's palace and some of these really
work and some of them really don't for
example when you first see Mos Eisley it
need to get a lot more different angles
and see a lot more creatures running
around but then they literally put
creatures in front of the camera there's
a robots going by and these giant
dinosaur things you literally can't see
what's going on why would you do that
you're missing an important scene the
first using of the force in the entire
thing but it's hard to make out because
there's this dinosaurs but in the way
it's totally nuts but then some things
are really neat to see like they shot a
scene of Jabba talking to Han Solo in
the first film that was later replaced
with the Greedo scene because they felt
the technology wasn't able to do it yet
well now it Ken is sort of the first
time we saw him was neat but he did look
kind of fake and suddenly he had these
perfect lip movements well that's weird
cuz a return of the Jedi it's still a
puppet with his mouth moving up and down
but now he conformed perfect syllables
they would later do another special
edition where they replaced him again
this time with
mouth moving up and down but he looked
even worse he still didn't look like you
was there he looks so incredibly fake
and on top of that the scene is
pointless because they leave the Greedo
scene still in there so job is just
repeating what we already heard and with
that said yeah let's talk about the
whole Han shot first thing in the
original version Greedo has a gun on han
Solo and Han Solo shoots and to get out
of it well Lucas didn't like that so he
had it where grito shoots first and then
Han Solo shoots back now taking out the
fact that this is a horrible looking
effect it literally looks like they just
Photoshop Harrison Ford's head over a
little everyone once again went nuts
that's not how it's supposed to go han
solo supposed to shoot first it's a
total betrayal of his character and
everything that Han Solo is it's
destroyed because of this one scene okay
it's stupid and not needed but it's
literally one second people are still
bitching and moaning about this dumbass
scene and it's ridiculous
dant like somebody told him that Luke
Skywalker was a Jawa or something it's
not that big a deal it's a different
take on an already popular scene neat
it's cool to see a new point of view why
the hell is this worth going apeshit
over yeah don't worry soon the prequels
will come and suddenly you'll have
nothing to complain about this will
still be the most offensive thing you
will ever see in a Star Wars film an
Empire Strikes Back the changes are a
little bit more minimal but look nice
Cloud City for example you can see a lot
more of and they even explain some
things that were a little confusing in
the original like when Lando Calrissian
gets on this little microphone and says
everybody evacuate the city
what Waymon where was that going to you
never see who's hearing it you just kind
of assume it's that one building in the
special edition you see it's a speaker
that reaches out to the entire city but
then again does he just have a little
microphone like that anywhere couldn't
anyone get on that microphone and
details details you also see a lot more
of a monster than text Luke in the
opening and you see how the hell Vader
got from Cloud City to the Star
Destroyer so quickly yeah that always
bother me in the original it's like he
was in one location and suddenly he's in
another here we actually see him take
the ship and go
back it's a little detail that's nice to
have Jedi most of the changes are good
too but there's still a couple things
are a little too crazy the dance
sequence in Jabba's palace for example
goes from this muddy dark dirty place to
this big musical number and there's a
lot of moving and dancing and it's just
a little too childish for me on top of
the fact that again the CG monsters
never really look like they're there but
whatever again it's neat to kind of see
a new point of view we also see a plan
at the end that we never saw in any of
the other versions but would later be in
the prequels yeah remember that planet
that's entirely a city you see it here
and on top of that if you look closely
you see a statue of the Emperor falling
over that's actually a nice little
detail so when they first came out I
didn't mind the special editions and I
still don't it's neat to see a brand new
angle on a lot of this and it's cool
that artist gets to go back revisit his
work and touch it up a bit
honestly I'm not even against the idea
of constantly going back and changing
things up yeah it's a little weird you
should probably leave good enough alone
but at the same time effects do keep
changing and they do keep updating I
kind of like the idea of comparing
different special editions and seeing
which effects hold up better how far
we're coming or how backwards weren't
going some of these CG effects look so
much better but then some of the
practical effects looked a lot better I
kind of like comparing and contrasting
so the idea of constantly going in and
updating it I don't mind what I do mind
is that we can't see the original that's
where I think people can get
legitimately upset we should be allowed
to compare and contrast why are we just
ignoring history if Abraham Lincoln
released another version of the
Gettysburg Address and said this is what
I really want to say that'd be neat I
would love to see that but if you went
back and said no this is what I said
what you heard is completely false and
doesn't exist I'm gonna erase it that
would be stupid
and for years Lucas never allowed the
original versions to be seen after the
VHS of the special editions came out
that was then the only version you could
get when it went to DVD it was the
special edition again except there were
even more changes in it yeah
now Hayden Christensen is at the end
instead of Luke's father
well what
a minute why isn't that it when McGregor
is ob1 then why isn't that younger Yoda
I get the idea of lying to bookend the
prequels and the other films but this
makes no sense
but again the biggest problem is we
weren't allowed to see the original on
blu-ray or DVD or any event it's like
Lucas was ashamed of the effects that
they weren't up to where they could be
at the time but they were groundbreaking
they were amazing they're still
impressive to look at sure they're a
little bit more fake now but again it's
neat to see the evolution of a project
in my opinion you can make as many
changes as you want as many versions as
you want I think it's a lot of fun to
look and compare them but if you don't
have the original you can't see what got
everybody interested in this to begin
with
you're denying newer generations what
the older generation saw and got sucked
into however I do hear that the original
versions are being released now if they
haven't been already now that it's out
of George Lucas's hands this is
definitely a good thing as we deserve to
see more than the VHS version of the
original films so on the whole I like
the special editions not everything
about them and some things I think are
downright awful but I think it's kind of
cool to see still a mess what they're
all working in but as long as we have
the original to always go back to I
don't see The Fault in it I don't care
if you call it Canon or not Canon a
version 2.5 6 whatever it's made it's
like seeing an artist go back and sketch
an old drawing that he did seeing how
his style has changed take it for what
it's worth
find what version you liked the most and
give it a watch
Oh